hey youtubers it's Charlie thank you
everyone that submitted questions for
this week's Walking Dead Q&A so there's
only four episodes left in the season
here are the titles episode 13 next week
is called forget episode 14 is titled
spend episode 15 is try and episode 16
the finale is titled conquer start your
theory crafting now I've tried to avoid
behind the scenes spoilers from from
them filming the episodes but obviously
the title of the finale is very loaded
that can mean a lot of things
the survivors conquering the save zone
someone else from outside coming in to
try conquer the safe zone we can talk
about it more as we get closer there are
a lot of people that think that Andrew
Lincoln has been teasing negan showing
up in the finale but unless I see some
more compelling evidence I'm gonna
assume that it's not gonna happen I
think it's more likely that the Wolves
like those scavengers would be the ones
to show up instead of the Savior's from
the comics but let's talk some safe zone
questions so here we go Cameron Peter
asks did anyone else notice Eugene
coming out from hiding behind a tree in
the background after Glenn's fight I
thought it was hilarious yeah definitely
Eugene totally you're not gonna change
his stripes Tiger don't change his
stripes
I think the episode was trying to tell
us that even though they're in this very
foreign place they're not gonna change
even even though Carol Rick might be
changing their clothes they're not gonna
change his characters next question the
bad man asks where the did Rick's gun go
I think we're all in consensus like just
looking from everyone's comments that
Enid's the one that took it she seems
like a scavenger that just goes around
the outside just looking for stuff to
grab she could also be related to some
of those people that got exiled next
question duncan games asked when i got
the first look at her smile i know she
was gonna do something bad so i think
the bad villain is going to be hurt or
aden what do you think so you're talking
about Deanna I actually I think that's
almost too on the nose
I think the villain is gonna be someone
that we're not expecting I definitely
think they don't want us to trust those
characters but it feels like a misdirect
like someone's gonna come in from left
field just in general the Walking Dead's
pretty good with stuff like that like
they'll make you think one character is
gonna do something and it'll wind up
being someone that you never suspected
it was like in season four when it
turned out that carol was the one that
burned those bodies that burned Karen's
body it was just something really awful
that you didn't expect from someone like
her obviously we know she's capable of
stuff like that now so it's not a
surprise anymore when she goes all WT
next question Chikara asks I'm a little
nervous about Rick or even Carol
becoming the next villain what do you
think oh I definitely think they're
gonna play with our heads in that sense
but no I don't think that they'll be the
like the big bads the show always does
that where it makes Rick seem like he's
crossing the line that's that's why I
like it so much because it's like hey
maybe the hero is gonna turn into the
villain it's like a very Batman thing
like Batman The Dark Knight but like I
just said I think the big villain like
whoever the the black hat wearing clear
yeah that guy is definitely evil villain
will be someone else usually it's a
little more rewarding when it's someone
you've already met and just didn't
suspect but the walking dead sometimes
it doesn't always do it that way
sometimes it's just like someone new
that comes in in the last couple of
episodes so I think we'll meet that
villain but for like episode 15 or so
hopefully by episode 15 if we don't meet
him by then then it's gonna be Deus Ex
mana I know I keep using male pronouns
but it's totally possible the villain
could be a woman next question hugs a
lot ass wasn't the scene where Rick was
walking down the street seeing Jesse's
husband smoking on the porch just a
dream no I think that was actually
happening her husband like Jesse's
someone from the comics and Jesse has a
husband in the comics so I think they're
just gonna do it that way I don't want
to talk too much about him just because
it gets into comic book spoilers but I
think Rick
Jesse Jesse's husband will play out like
it did in the comics in case you don't
want to read the comics and you don't
want spoilers I'll just say bullies
never win on The Walking Dead so you
know I mean everyone's kind of a bully
but the biggest bullies never win next
question Julia asks why do you think the
Carroll was putting on the act when she
was being interviewed I think she wants
to get a sense for them before they get
a sense for her she doesn't want them to
know what she's capable of so the
underestimate her that means if [ __ ]
goes down and the survivors need to take
Alexandria they won't be looking at
Carroll as a threat so she'll be able to
take down a whole bunch of people so
it's Carol doing a little battle
planning just playing it safe don't lay
your cards down on the table until you
see your opponent's cards next question
infamous Adam asks do you think that the
Walking Dead has any plans for the Noah
character or really just be in the
background well I don't think they keep
him on if they didn't have a plan for
him what I'd like to see is him get
Glenn's plot from the comics so I know a
lot of you have read the comics just
please use spoiler tags if you're gonna
comment on that but that's that's what
I'll say hopefully Glenn from
comics without getting into super
specifics I feel like that's an outcome
that everyone would really enjoy
comic-book readers and non comic-book
readers next question Cody Johnson asks
do you think that they're setting up
Jesse to be Andrea from the comics I
think I think what's happening is is
they're taking a couple comic book
characters that they don't have in the
show right now and giving aspects of
those two a couple different people so
they're just mixing and matching so no
one character is gonna be Andrea from
the comics for those that have read the
comics and are totally confused right
now Andrea is just like a really strong
female character that does a couple of
notable things it's like really critical
to some of the big WTF moments Alexandra
Breckinridge does kind of look like
Andrea from the comics but her character
jesse is a comic book character so I
think she'll mostly follow her storyline
with maybe a couple of moments from
Andrea storyline and again if you
haven't read the comics that just means
that she'll be involved in some WTF
moments Jesse in the comics was more of
a background character she had a very
minor role so I think they wanted to
make Alexandra Breckenridge's version of
her character bigger so they're just
giving her some Andrea stuff next
question
BH 1747 asks where was the priest this
whole episode yeah a lot of you guys
were asking about Gabriel where's
Gabriel I think he was just hanging out
in the house and walking around like
everyone else they just they didn't have
time to show every single character it's
kind of like Eugene you know he just
kind of appeared in the background every
once in a while he wasn't critical to
the plot this week but they're in a
community now that is trying to maintain
a certain level of society so I think
Deanna at some point if she hasn't
already
we'll ask Gabriel to become their
official priest and start holding church
services next question azar asks what
about Morgan when is that awesome mofo
coming back that is a good question so
based on what we saw in this episode and
the last time we saw him in the
mid-season finale it seems like he is
behind the group so they wouldn't go
through the finale this year without
showing him again hopefully he'll show
up in like episode 15 Scott Campbell
said a long time ago like after the
first episode in season 5 that Morgan's
story was gonna take place apart from
the group but at some point he will have
to intersect with them again there was a
big rumor that he was gonna be in the
season 4 finale that didn't pan out that
didn't end up happening so I think it
would be a really fun awesome WTF if he
showed up his [ __ ] was going down in the
finale this season I mean what better
time for him to show
and full riot gear with a bunch of
assault rifles than in an episode titled
conquer but thank you so much for so
many questions everyone these are always
a ton of fun to do real quick reminder
on their on the rest of the episode so
there's four more episodes they're
supposed to air each week there's not
gonna be a break so we'll get like one
episode right after the other till the
last one that actually reminds me
congratulations to this week's giveaway
winner Alex lust you win a $20 Amazon
gift card just be sure to message me on
the back end of my channel so I get your
contact info so don't forget that's
actually the title of next week's
episode be sure to subscribe to get that
video I'll post it after the episode
airs I'm expecting us to learn more
about enid what's going on with her
learn more about what Deanna's grand
plan is and learn more about new threats
outside the community there's also a new
episode of Gotham tonight I'll just I'll
post that after the episode airs so
while you guys wait for that you can
click here for my Walking Dead episode
12 video if you haven't seen it and you
can click here for my latest Game of
Thrones video all about dark Sansa so
thank you so much for watching I'll see
you guys tonight
high fives
you